(upbeat music playing)
A lot of work goes into a short,
late night stand-up set.
Join me J.P. Buck, as I
spotlight the comedians
who came up with some of
my favorite CONAN sets.
This is, The Set Up.
[Conan] Please welcome the
very funny Daniel Sloss!
(upbeat music playing)
I remember, well, to be fair,
I think in your head you were like,
right, we're gonna do the set,
we're gonna do it on television.
I never believed I was
going to be on CONAN
until the curtains pulled back.
And it wasn't until I physically was there
and I heard it like,
that was the moment where I was like,
oh okay, now they're not
gonna take it away from you.
So when I went, when we
were talking about my set,
when we were booking and
we were organizing dates,
the entire time I was
like this isn't happening.
Something will happen, they like I,
something else will come up
or they'll realize their mistake.
And then we start getting on
the plane on the way there,
now I was excited,
I'm like this feels like
it might be happening.
And then I got to the hotel,
and it was like the day of the recording,
and we go along to the studios
and it's all very exciting.
And I don't know if you remember this,
but I'm just like oh my
god, I might actually,
this might be the time I
get to perform on CONAN.
And then Nelson Mandela died.
It was the day Nelson Mandela died.
Because I remembered, how
selfish I am as a human being.
One of the greatest men
who has ever lived died
and my first reaction was,
I bet I don't get to be on CONAN anymore.
Like that's, it's too sad,
they'll pull tonight's show,
I'm not going to get the moment.
I know, I know. I understand
now what I was doing,
but at the time, I just,
Well, what's worse, losing that spot,
because of Nelson Mandela dying
or actually having to go out and be funny
the day of his passing?
Yeah.
What's worse?
Well, I mean,
oh, you know, when you put it
that way, now I look worse,
now it looks worse that I did it.
Knowing that while everyone was,
while everyone was mourning,
I was like, hold on, hold on,
hold on, everyone, everyone,
let's not remember him,
let's get back to
straight white men, okay?
Please, back here, all eyes
back to me, come on now.
Possibly the whitest
comedian we could book.
Yeah.
That was, that was, I
mean, it looks bad on us,
it's like, this is our response,
our response to Nelson Mandela passing is,
here, here's the whitest
comedian we can find.
Yeah, and then, and then Jim Gaffigan.
(upbeat music playing)
There's a joke that was
supposed to be in the set
right after this.
That was the one that I told you,
I don't think it's gonna go over well,
I don't think it's, the
audience is gonna love it,
why don't we just cut it?
Yeah.
Which was the obesity versus gay joke.
Oh yes, yes, we did that on, and you were,
you were absolutely right to
make that call, because when I,
I don't know because, you, I
mean, I told you, I was like,
I don't think you should do
this and you pulled it out,
but then you put it in the set that,
you came back two months
later on the show,
and you did the joke there,
and it got an applause break.
A country that believes
that obesity is a disease,
but homosexuality is a choice.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so if you're fat,
don't worry about it
that's not your fault,
you were probably born that
way, but if you're gay,
must be something you ate.
(audience laughing)
Was it penis?
(audience clapping)
Maybe I just don't know what I'm doing.
I mean, that's absolutely not the case,
but sure, that's much better,
that's much better than
me self-reflecting,
so let's go for that one yes.
(J.P. laughing)
I'm a terrible boyfriend, like,
you always have to do the things
when you're in a
relationship, for example,
telling a girl that she's
the most beautiful girl
in the world.
I never told my ex-girlfriend
that she was the most
beautiful girl in the world.
And that was for personal reasons.
It's cause she wasn't.
(audience laughing)
Not in a bad way.
She was very good
looking, but my logic is,
there are 3.5 billion
women on earth,
there can be only one, most
beautiful girl in the world,
that's how it works,
that's what that means.
(audience laughing)
so, all I'm saying is that, statistically,
probably wasn't her.
Has statistics ever
helped you win an argument
in a relationship?
No, no, it's,
not in a relationship, cause,
relationship arguments are
never about statistics,
deep down.
(both laughing)
you learn, now that I
am in a relationship,
you learn that it's not about being right,
it's about being happy.
There are a lot of jokes that,
that's like the biggest,
the biggest reaction to me
may come at a punchline.
And then the tags, kind
of peter off a little bit.
For me, this joke kinda goes
here, and then you tag it,
and that tag for me, is
what is the crescendo.
Oh the tag coming up?
Yeah.
There can only be one, most
beautiful girl in the world.
That's how it works,
that's what that means.
(audience laughing)
so, all I'm saying is that, statistically,
probably wasn't her, okay.
(audience laughing)
She was livid, right?
She stormed out halfway
through my PowerPoint, right.
Just left, crying and phoning her mom,
Just because you paint
a ridiculous scenario,
(both laughing)
you reveal that this
argument is now taking place
at like a lecture hall.
Yeah, yeah. It goes from, like,
they're slightly on my side
because they can follow my
twisted mathematical logic of it,
and then you pan out to
reveal the scene of it,
they weren't imagining it,
this is literally how I'm
explaining it to my girlfriend,
I am a nightmare.